[Music]
let's actually take a second to talk
about the actual differences in Dragon
Ball faces because surprise they
actually do exist so the main way faces
differentiate in Dragon Ball is via the
eyes and the first type we have is type
one these eyes do not connect all the
way around and have different properties
for where the lines are depending on the
angle of the face then there's type two
these have contiguous angular lines for
the eyes and are probably what you most
associate with Dragon Ball faces then we
have type three let's call them tenens
shinan eyes they are contiguous
connected to the brow but have concave
curves to them that make them pretty
unique and then lastly we have type four
the Android eyes these are similar to
type 3 but are often Slimmer and do not
connect to the brow and of course there
are edge cases outside of these main
four but draw Goku with type four eyes
or Vegeta with type one eyes and it's
going to look uh weird